December's border encounters coming in
over 251
000 the highest month ever recorded
Farmers on the ground Arizona telling
Fox news this week their livelihoods are
being threatened
well this is not just a border Community
problem
this is a United States problem not this
Christmas but Christmas C4 I had 40
Haitians living in a field for a week
anytime anybody enters our field we have
to Cordon that off and flag it and we
don't Harvest that area
Yuma County supervisor for Arizona
Jonathan lines joins us now Jonathan
great to have you on the program uh
first of all let's uh good morning to
you let's let's get some sense on the
ground your county we have the numbers
they're staggering once again uh border
encounters here for the month of
December what is it like on the ground
there in Arizona
that's a little bit overwhelming you
know it's not just our AG gets affected
but our Hospital our local 9-1-1 our
ngos it's just staggering to see the
numbers continue to climb we've had a
little bit of a pause for the last
couple of weeks with bad weather but we
anticipate those numbers to continue as
they have been at over a thousand a day
it's just unprecedented to see this type
of traffic and people coming from all
over the world
specifically in the areas where we had
the containers which were temporary and
the federal Administration or Washington
has still failed to act to keep our
border secure
yeah you know it's interesting we have
talked often about some of the impacts
on those local communities as you point
out with the hospitals one of the things
that's really coming into Focus now is
the effect that it also has on our food
supply so your county in particular Yuma
County this is a fascinating statistic
90 percent of all leafy vegetables in
the United States that you're finding
there at your Supermarket grown in Yuma
County so what's the impact on that on
those leafy vegetables there in Yuma
from illegal immigration
well our Farmers Growers Harvesters have
had to take Extraordinary Measures in
order to protect their product when
there is an undocumented entry into a
field the farmers have to go back then
they have to test they have to like uh
has been mentioned they have to Corden
that area off Colin USDA call in Arizona
Ag Department and make sure that all the
protocols are being followed so it costs
a lot more money and in and already uh
expensive time for our food supply so
the border is directly as you can see uh
in front of a lot of our growing areas
so we you know we follow up on the
federal government to step up they made
a commitment to us my air Chris was here
last year told us that he was going to
plug these gaps um he did he failed to
act Ducey acted those gaps are open
again we're concerned our Growers are
concerned just because we are extremely
focused on the food security issue we
have the best protocols in the nation
that's something that I wanted to
emphasize and every time that there's an
undocumented entry into the field they
go through Extraordinary Measures to
protect and test and make sure that
nothing is contaminated
so it's time loss it's labor loss it's
Farmers being dedicated to things other
than putting food as cheaply as possible
onto the plates of America absolutely to
deal with all of this yeah yes Jonathan
lines thank you getting up early there
in Arizona and letting us know what's
happening that as you point out others
will point out not just a problem in
Yuma then everywhere across the country
thank you
thank you all right I'm Steve Ducey I'm
Brian Kilmeade and I'm Ainsley Earhart
and click here to subscribe to the Fox
News YouTube page to catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis